[Applause]
one of the people I love to listen to on
Twitter is Marjorie Taylor green I don't
know if you know Marjorie Taylor green
but she's really having a moment uh
Trump is considering her as a running
mate in 2024. oh there she is yes and
she's also gotten a lot of incredible
press and when the Republicans take over
Congress in 11 days she's going to be
very important there so we thought today
would be a good time to do 24 things you
don't know
uh if you like to hear them I'm sure you
would for example I've never been in a
store without demanding to see the
manager foreign
I have three kids two in high school and
one who was murdered by Hillary Clinton
my greatest fears are snakes spiders and
Jews
how we let a few of those groaners back
in
a relationship I sometimes open the door
completely unarmed
I was once kicked off truth social for
not comparing something to Nazis
laughs
my mom drank while she was pregnant with
me and even more after she met me
I will work with the Republicans who
dislike me because there's no eye in
team I think
classrooms are full of groomers I'm
trailer schooling my kids
I would have liked Schindler's List if
it was shorter not the movie the list of
Jews he saved
[Applause]
if I could meet anyone living or dead
I'd prefer living because if I was dead
what's the point